yah welcome our spin doors welcome to
this video as spenders turkey do we get
benko gambit no button benoni yeah I
don't you don't see that too often
nowadays it's kind of three out of
fashion and there's no particular reason
for that especially on the amateur level
it is a very interesting opening it is
risky of course and there for a little
bit yeah not played so much on the
highest level but um on let's say normal
normal level there is really no reason
not to play this opening it is
completely fine okay keep forgetting the
move order Sam yeah I one with this
noisy three line which is I think quite
nice it gives some white pretty pretty
decent chances to attack if is f for a
move or is it too risky a four-night h7
I can go to H form maybe that's a bit
risky but interesting continuation
check the bishop is weird on h4 but it
takes some important squares under
control oh wow really okay okay and play
this anyway no use to spend time on this
i justwell play it quickly oh just doing
that
mmm so I can go e 6 I can take g4 that's
difficult difficult to assess okay it's
going 6 f takes Bishop g4 is it's
definitely him I was I was I wanted to
say is definitely good for wide but he
just played it maybe maybe it's not so
clear I am I don't know but it looks
very very shaky karaoke money for f5
maybe f5 and then going coming in with
Queen age 6 mm or taking with the pawn
first bishop jakes then f 50 hard to say
yeah how to hard to assess him it's
clearly a nice attack but how good it is
at the same check 26 or 95 are coming
you're not to hire or 24 I don't know
okay it's preparing rookie aid so maybe
I have to play Queenie form for the
capture on g-form check look f8 is able
to take with the with a night so yeah 95
I guess so
95 94 I don't know I also cookie 5 me I
have the crankcases quite worrisome
still I don't really know how you can
play it instant moves in this type of
position but I'm probably just such a
backpack bet tactician that I cannot
imagine how people do that everything's
hanging here and he just plays instantly
okay Luke g8 is this coming may be
either for me it's got Queenie one look
fa this night of age still yeah and he's
got the Jade ki from the lead this this
kind of move
notta for that was Queenie one otherwise
no therefore was of course good Luke g8
now I go queen of three what Queen h5
Queen age five might be better actually
because it keeps night f4 in the
position
kids got this chicken t1
oh yeah it's very tough he is playing
this very quickly and I mean I don't see
a winsome don't know if there is one I
mean this is time morning
check okay so here check check check we
stay I don't see a maid unfortunately
check it's it's all very close to that
but I don't see a direct made check
check
it's kind of weird but I didn't see one
check okay black resins when either look
up yet I mean I know this has been an
all-time subject here in this video's
but I don't understand how people can
play moves and have a second when the
board is completely burning I mean I
don't know I don't know it it's probably
probably a problem that that I'm alone
with okay so we had this this very
complicated position there were many
many interesting possibilities along the
way of course I mean here I really
didn't think he can can do that but ok
now the edge that actually says that
Queen d3 is interesting and Bishop d3 is
interesting right ok this was clearly
giving me a good attack but it was hard
to check how to assess completely went
there ok I cannot do this because of a
thought because of rupee aid yeah and
this is indeed the problem so I had to
play here dis you played instantly check
there were some alternative rook evade
or whatever and check that ok so and now
I went to d5 yeah this is a position
where you can think quite a long time
Queen h5 is the computer move was a
slight edge for wife then Bishop 33 yeah
tough tough to say yep when Queen takes
a for was good according to stock fish
yeah threatening ok but he took four
seconds for Queenie six queen air force
was too strong for the maid threat i'm
suspecting made
and I don't have a great continuation
here this is not on check check now
Queenie for was very strongly I have to
I have to play something back here so 95
was a mistake it's it's it's AB it's
bound to happen now that there are
mistakes in this kind of position okay
take sticks and now we'll give 7 I
retain some attacking chances but it's
very complicated of course okay took and
all this immediately yeah i was thinking
you should do something about the jeep
on yahoo could be worse i was winning
actually with ruchi one I cannot keep
the pole ash what I should do is
actually to take and play here four
chances of a perpetual yeah after this
I'm winning at least it took 10 seconds
for that move okay check yeah and here
white white definitely definitely
winning now def fibers even a bit better
chocolate this is enough to enough to
win he cannot cannot really defend this
threatening rookie 7 and g7 check this
is this is giving away the rook and then
not only that i mean the the pawn will
will promote yeah okay thanks for
watching